في دراسه حديثه تم اجراؤها في جامعه تكساس
الامريكيه تبين ان استهلاك المانجو له
تاثير ايجابي على الاشخاص الذين يعانون من
مرض التهاب الامعاء نتائج الدراسه اظهرت
ان استهلاك المانجو الطازج يعد مساعدا
هاما وله دور كبير في العلاج التقليدي
للحالات التي تعاني من التهاب الامعاء
خصوصا في الحالات الخفيفه والمعتدله وذلك
بسبب احتوائها على مضادات الاكسده التي
تحد من امراض الامعاء الالتهابيه المانجو
ايضا تعز الهضم من خلال احتوائها على
مجموعه من الانزيمات الهاضمه التي تقوم
بتحطيم جزيئات الطعام الكبيره ليسهل
امتصاصها وتجزا الكربوهيدرات المعقده تعزز
صحه القلب وذلك بفضل احتوائها على كل من
الالياف والفيتامينات والبوتاسيوم التي
تعمل على تحسين عمل الشرايين وتقلل خطر
الاصابه بامراض القلب وكل ذلك يصب في
مصلحه المصابين بالسمنه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات